[Music]
let me start with a brief introduction
about myself first of all I'm more
conveniently referred to as DD for
obvious reasons so I I used to be in the
UC Berkeley amp lab that Joey referred
to earlier and so that and that's where
I started building spark streaming with
mati and it was our grads our grad
school project which turned out to be
something much larger than what we
imagined so and right now I'm it's been
almost four or five years since then and
right now I'm focused on actually
building the next generation beyond
sparks doing which is structure
streaming and so I'm an engineer at data
brakes we are I'm part of the stream
team and our team water is we make all
your dreams come true
also BMC member of a Paris part
ok so here is your one slide about spark
for those three folks spark if you is a
unified producing engine that allows you
to build all sorts of cool big data
applications wheat streaming
applications machine learning
applications graph pressing applications
in java scala python r whatever language
you prefer tell us build all these all
sorts of cool applications that read
data from all different kinds of storage
because part can talk to a lot a lot of
them and allows you to run in those
applications on lot of different
environments B DC to guinea cloud Hadoop
er and me sauce and we recently added
the kubernetes in the last Apache 2.0
release so hopefully it all up to speed
everyone knows exactly what about you
Sparky's oh okay so I'm yet to talk
about actually about data pipelines and
this is something that pretty much every
company dealing with data has to build
you guys know about that but here is
where I would like to start from our
perspective on it this is data pipelines
in at 10,000 feet view and many data
pipelines just kind of at a high level
fit into this model you have
unstructured data streams of data coming
in
you the first step is actually dump it
as fast as possible in the possibility
unstructured form with maybe a little
bit of cleanup and stuff but then
there's usually a separate process that
is going to ETL the data from your data
Lake where the data is dumped into a
more structured form in some sort of
data warehouse and then the data is
ready for for their analytics like doing
what whatever sort of analytics you want
to do now this her high-level looks
clean understandable but the
implementation of this is really clean
so here is a data pipeline of a fortune
100 company that database is currently
working with and this is how it looked
like before we came in so they had
trillions of records coming in from all
their network infrastructure their
server infrastructure in their own data
center they have bro logs a lot of low
level logs application level logs all
coming in and being dumped in multiple
data like spread across multiple clouds
and then there's usually a separate
complex ETL process to read all those
out a util them and put them into
multiple
dedicated data warehouses and their
multiple because each data warehouse is
kind of designed and tuned for one
particular end use case for example
alerting is requires certain kind of
database reporting requires different
kind of database searching would require
a different kind of data warehouse and
so there so they had essentially this
messy architecture of multiple data
Lakes multiple data warehouses and
things don't very well integrate across
each other etcetera so besides the
general messiness of the whole thing
what the major problems they had which
is why they came to us is that you have
hours of delay in accessing the data
from the data from the time when the
data is generated at their servers or
network equipments by the time it
reaches the data where else where they
can do a useful stuff with it it is ours
really ours and that was not acceptable
when they have what to do critical stuff
like intrusion detection as fast
things like that and each of these
systems are very expensive to scale
because data warehouses often are not
built to really scale horizontally there
and data is locked in very proprietary
format so so pulling data out from the
the structure it out from those data
warehouses can be often clunky slow etc
and they did not have any support for
any sort of advanced analytics like
machine learning and stuff because those
data warehouses were not designed for
specific for those purposes so when we
came in we saw them we work we work with
them figured out a cleaner approach and
that led to something like this and
that's what I'm going to talk about
today so we replaced their complex
ETL logic etc too with something like
with spark spark structure streaming
that's going to be my main focus after
they stopped the in terms rather than
use their storage solutions of variety
of data lakes and data warehouses we
went ahead and designed and built data
big Delta for them I'm going to talk a
little bit about that towards end and
then what Delta X Delta solves their
storage problems in such a nice way that
now you can use spark for any kind of
operations like all the downstream
requirements like Galler ting monitoring
etcetera all of them can be built on top
of just these two systems so and that
essentially allowed the data to be
usable within minutes if not seconds it
was easy to horizontally scale all of
these all the formats are essentially go
pen so you can you're not locked into a
particular data warehouse solution and
it of course it was built on spark so it
automatically enables advanced analytics
like machine learning etc you can
integrate all of that in the same in the
same of your pen ecosystem alright let's
talk about struct assuming first the way
I would like to present usually about
song siming is to start with the
philosophy the philosophy that we had
the sort of the realization we had when
we designed structure streaming is that
the end user that is you should not have
to reason about the complexities of
streaming late data out of order or I
will all of these complexities
getting out what to do when to drop data
etc you should not have to reason about
all of these you should have to simply
write simple queries as if you're
pressing batch data that's usually
simpler and it's Foggs job to
automatically figure out how to convert
that simple query into a more
incremental streaming version so that
that can run on streams so to do that we
realize that we need us one simplifying
simple unifying abstraction and we
realize that tables are essentially that
one unifying abstraction you can have
tables you can have your streams which
Reedus tables essentially every new data
or new record that derives in a stream
it's like a new row being appended to
two tables and so we have these tables
as a common abstraction that can
represent both unbounded data which are
streams as well as bounded data which
are batch tables so let's to understand
how this signifying abstraction helps
let's walk through a simple example it
may be simple but often building
something this simple in other system
becomes very clunky and complicated so
let me demonstrate how easy it becomes
in the system for example let's say you
have a JSON data coming in through Kafka
what you want to do is parse the nested
JSON into more structured form and write
it out as part case so that you can now
do interactive queries on that part a
table and obviously we want to ensure
into an fault tolerance guarantee so
that you don't want to drop data or have
data duplicated so to start with this
first you need to define what your
source of the data is and that's these
four lines of code where you are
specifying that I want to read from data
from Kafka which is the format Kafka I
want where do I want to read from which
is what servers Kafka is what topic I
want to read and load it and so Kafka is
among the few built-in support we have
files and we have also cases in our data
breaks offering
and you can also combine data from
multiple different sources using Union
join etc what this returns is
essentially what we call a data frame
and a and data frame is programming the
main programming abstraction for Apache
spark so data frame do the the simplest
way to think of data frames is that they
are semantically equivalent to a table
it's a bunch of rows which have a well
defined schema and since and and going
back to the unifying model the tables
can be both bounded and unbounded data
frames can we both represent both static
data as well as streaming data so it
gave this single API for representing
both kinds of data and and the cool
thing or data frame is that there are
multiple different variations of the API
that you can use to program depending on
whatever you are comfortable with for
example these did the spar Gator films
are very similar to Python pandas or our
data frames for those who are familiar
with it typically data scientists are
more familiar with those set of things
or you can you can express your business
logic in pure sequel and and get data
frames out of it as well
typically BN lists are more familiar
with sequel and then if you want to
write something a lot more complex like
very custom processing in a MapReduce
cell fashion you can write you have this
variation of data frame called data set
which are essentially statically typed
data frames and so there you can write
your function literals and lambdas in a
fully statically typed language like
Java and Scala and you get full compile
time type safety for for complicate
stuff and not a pigeonhole that one one
data scientist should use this and data
engineer use this the nice thing is that
you can pick whatever hammer you want to
use for whatever nail you have and you
get the same semantics across all these
different variations and the same
performance guarantees you're not
restricted to any using one or the other
so going back to the query so what this
returns is essentially a cough cough car
data frame
where and where each row is like a
record inside cough
but it kind of expresses each row in
terms of these clear schema for these
columns where we have the binary key the
binary value the topic and partition
where the the record came from the
offset of the record and the kafka
timestamp so now since it looks like a
table it'd be like a table you can do
all sorts of operations on it like a
table for example let's do some
transformations so here remember what I
want to do I want to basically treat the
data inside kafka as json and parse it
out so that's what I do if I cast the
binary value to string and then apply
this function call from JSON on with the
specific schema to to put two parts of
the data and from jason is one of the
hundreds of built-in sequel functions
that automatically are super optimized
based on because we have been optimizing
that for over last two three years that
you can use to make all your complete
processing much easier and you can
obviously write your own user-defined
functions you can write your own lambdas
you can write your own MapReduce style
functions you can invoke machine
learning modules through that so all of
that can just fit into these this data
frame data set programming interface
finally we want to write the data the
the parsed out data out into park' so
that's what we specify as a sink or we
transform and so you can specify in this
case we are specifying that we won't
write it out to a park if format into a
particular path which is our pocket
table and while we have native support
for files in Kafka you there's also a
method called for each where you can
specify your arbitrary code to write it
out to arbitrary systems and and
depending on your sink implementation
area for each implementation if you
write it out transactionally then you
get into ant fault well and exactly ones
guarantees but to get that you also need
to specify two more things one is
checkpoint location which is where the
spark will definitely save all the
necessary data to
figure out how much it has processed and
therefore what it needs to do process
for tolerance and that is the one that
crucial for getting the exactly ones
guarantees and also you need to specify
thing more processing level details like
trigger which is how do you want to
actually execute it when do you want to
immediate you want to emit data every
one minute or every 10 seconds or
continuously which is a new execution
mode in spark 2.0 I'll talk about it
later so you need to specify these
pricing details and then call start when
you call start what happens is that
sparked the the course this foxy
collision takes this query wait in data
frames data set a sequel and converted
it converts it into a standardized
logical plan then it converts to an to
figure saw what is the best an optimal
way of executing this logical plan into
a more optimized plan and from that
optimized plan it essentially figures
out how to run this code incrementally
on it's automatically and therefore and
and and generates a series of
incremental execution plans which
executes snoo batches of data as new
data arrive on the streams so SPARC
takes care of automatically streaming
fiying your query from the very batch
table like query that you've written and
it also automatically takes care of the
checkpointing based on the checkpoint
location you have provided it's usually
HDFS st or some sort of fault tolerant
storage format where spark will save all
the necessary offset information like
what cough cough sets have been
processed it will save it you know using
JSON enough so that its future it is
always forward compatible with git is
always forward compatible and with that
you get exactly into ends once guarantee
and you also get the guarantee that even
if your code changes within certain
constraints you can always recover and
start where the previous version of the
code left off and then this is often
very useful where let's say you have you
receive some corrupt data and your query
failed because it could handle it you
can add an addition
filter to filter those corrupt data out
and start where it left off going back
to the query so this is what we started
to build and what the end result is that
you have this query that can convert
unstructured data from Kafka in a
structured format of park' making that
available for further downstream
processing within seconds this is great
and this is this when we did when we did
this a couple of years ago this was by
far very different and a leap forward
than what was possible without before
structure streaming and this by the way
is really fast for example we built the
Yahoo benchmark to run on both spark and
flink and we we and to compare the raw
throughput performance and in a 40 cold
10 cluster setting we were almost 3x
faster than the nearest computer Apache
flink and for you guys that essentially
means for your requirements it will be
3x cheaper to run on apache spark than
anywhere else so let me focus on another
aspect of this query so note that the
core business logic of how you're
transforming data is in just in these
couple of lines whatever is around it is
essentially peripheral code that
specifies whether it reader where to
read and write from and how to process
but in this case if you just flipped the
that peripheral Court ready to use read
and write instead of read stream and
write stream then your query
automatically becomes a batch query not
a streaming query and the cool thing is
that your business are equally mains
completely unchanged whatever
complicated map function reduced
function you have applied all of that
doesn't need to change at all because
it's the same API same statically typed
API it's exactly the same so you can
build libraries of these transformations
and just use it in whatever context you
want so you write a business logic
independent of what is your future
execution mode going to be and for in
terms
would you dare have therefore have three
choices either you want to run it as a
batch as a bad job or an interactive job
which if you want to do it periodically
in your data pipeline you will have
hours at best minutes of latency but you
can execute on demand you can optimize
your execution costs very well schedule
it on gone spot nodes and stuff but you
are going to get really really high
throughput you can choose to put it on
our the default streaming execution
engine them the microbats engine and you
get low latency of the order of seconds
but you also still get the same high
throughput because it's reusing the
exact all the same machinery that the
SPARC batch engine is using the coarse
parts equal optimized engine and
recently as of last month in spa 2.3 we
also have this continuous streaming mode
which gives you all Trello millisecond
level agencies at the cost of slightly
higher resource usage because unlike the
microbial model here you are statically
allocating resources in the cluster to
continuously process data as opposed to
in micro batch where you are you are
gathering resources as and when data
arrives so it is much more so one is
more efficient the other gives you lower
latency you have the you have the
ability to choose what execution mode
you want without your query changing so
2.3 has an experimental release which
works on non aggregation just simple ETL
kind of stuff I highly encourage you to
try it out the next step usually that
people do beyond this simple ETL kind of
pipelines are event time aggregations
and and even time aggregations people
usually think of windowing windowing
based on the event time and in in our
API windowing is just another form of
grouping essentially you are taking
every record and putting it multiple
groups of windows what whichever window
time windows that that record falls in
based on the event time of that record
and you can specify so so to specify
this when doing you have to specify what
is the timestamp column
and what sort of windowing do you want
in terms of how the window length and
this and how how the window moves and so
you specific you can specify only
time-based windows and you can combine
that with other kind of grouping as well
together this is very sequel ish and
stuff and of course we support
user-defined aggregate functions as well
underneath under the hood what happens
is that to continuously compute these
gag relations your the engine needs to
remember what was the partial aggregate
every time a new data is processed so
that it can continue where it left off
and and the way it is done is basically
by maintaining distributed state in the
cluster so on giving us during the spark
cluster on all the worker nodes this the
state is maintained as in memory state
although it is backed into as a writer
ad log in HDFS any state changes so what
happens is that in every micro batch it
reads the previous state Gupta's
aggregates and writes out as the new
state to be and an automatically synced
to the fault tolerance storage s3 HDFS
whatever and this all happens seamlessly
under no hood you don't need to worry
about it all you need to do is specify
the checkpoint location and it takes
care of everything and you get the same
exactly once fault tolerance guarantees
that you expect out of spark this way
also automatically handles late data and
this is why the user doesn't really need
to worry about it too much so if you
happen to receive if the only happens is
receive some record that is out of order
and late all it will do is it will
figure out that oh it needs to update an
older bucket rather than the newest
bucket was actually updating and since
all of that information is already
present instead let's just go ahead and
update there are the right bucket and
therefore late data gets taken care of
automatically but the side effect of
that is that the engine really doesn't
know when to stop updating old buckets
when it can kind of
close the bucket and say nope I'm not
this is not going to be updated so I'm
just going to not throw it out of state
and and because it doesn't know it can
never throw out anything so the state
will keep going indefinitely
to avoid doing that the you don't want
that to happen usually because more
state means more memory more resource
requirements in the cluster so to avoid
doing that what we what we are
sponsoring supports is watermarking and
for those who are not familiar with
whatever marking is it's essentially
like a moving threshold that is trailing
behind the maximum event time system as
seen so for example if at any point of
time among all the records that has will
process the maximum event time is 12:30
p.m. and you have specified this
trailing gap which is called the
watermark delay to be ten minutes then
the at that point of time your watermark
is at 12:20 and what and what the engine
can automatically do is that any record
that is older than a watermark that is
that has been delayed by more than 10
minutes it can automatically start
dropping that data and so for example if
you are aggregating then your data if we
give it as let's say five minute delay
then it is late but it will be still
allowed to aggregate and update the
counts and the engine you are going to
figure out when to how much of the state
to maintain to get the correctness
guarantees within those bounds but if
any record is more than 10 minutes late
then it will automatically be dropped
and it's corresponding buckets in the
state will be automatically cleared out
it's very easy to specify this 10 minute
trailing what gap this watermark delay
by just specifying this method with
watermark what is the event timestamp
column and what is the trailing delay
and the system takes care of
automatically figuring out at the run
time and when it's running what is the
current max event time so it will add
vaguely track based on the as data comes
in so the x axis here is the processing
time which is the real wall clock time
and as data is coming in the y-axis
which is the even time it can move up
and down in the event time and it will
the system will automatically track what
is the max even time and based on that
it will keep updating what is the
current watermark which is the red line
here and based on that watermark value
it will figure out if whether the record
is late but still will still give of the
watermark or if it's actually older than
the watermark and based on that it will
decide whether to consider it or not and
I've died for a lot of these I have more
detailed explanations in my blog post so
please take a look at that so I am NOT
going to be able to cover a lot of the
more advanced operations in structure
streaming do we have blog posts and
multiple talks about that I highly
encourage you to take a look at those
but things like automatic streaming
deduplication we recently added support
for stream stream joins we have always
supported stream by joins but we also
have seen stream joints and we have the
ability to arbitrary stateful processing
where you want to do things like session
ization and stuff and all in all of
these cases you can use watermark to
automatically clean up state or do
custom state clean up yourself in the
case of garbage we say to proceed
anyways so going back to the original
picture of how we build the new data
pipeline using apache spark so the
second part of this building this
end-to-end pipeline was data with Delta
and since I really can't go into too
much detail about one of our 1400
customers on how things look like let me
use our own example of how we do ETL
editor breaks to kind of explain what
are the problems we actually faced while
using structured streaming alone and how
we came up with the idea of data because
Delta and how that helped immensely us
and there and and therefore we made a
product out of it and goddess can use it
as well so we had essentially the same
problem as most of you face we
have dead events coming in from Kafka
these are our users logs from we manage
the managed service in the cloud so
running on various different cloud
environments AWS as your different
locations we have all the events coming
in through Kinnison Kafka now we want to
do one essentially streaming analytics
on it we want to do build long-term
reports on it and so how do you build
this so when we started building this we
the first thing we went about was we
started building seeming analytic
dashboard using structure streaming
where it failed is that we can't Kafka
can store only maybe you seven days or
maybe few weeks of data and anything
more than that is probably really
expensive so what do we do about
reporting and conditional queries so we
had to build another pipeline that takes
the same data and puts it in your data
Lake so we have your typical lambda
architecture we have two different
pipelines which automate and then you so
now with the with the data Lake we we
can do reporting and stuff but that but
then we ran into other problems of
having two different pipelines so these
two by pipelines even though you use
different we use the same business logic
thanks to spark structure streaming and
sparks equal and data frames there were
still certain kinds of drifts things
that we saw in the swimming pipeline
that had to ignore certain amount late
data but the the actual bias pipeline
had all the data sometimes you need to
cross validate to figure out what is the
div between that and if cross and that
cross validation often leads to that we
need to reprocess certain parts of the
data because things were wrong so that
that that led to another challenge that
how do you validate across to these two
different kinds of pipelines how do you
reprocess the data data in the data lake
such that it can be kept always correct
and stuff and it's the golden source of
truth for any kind of monitoring the
other set of problems that we ran into
is query performance well when you're
dumping data into a data Lake from us
from a stream pipeline a common problem
that you run into is that you have
really tight
defense because you're dumping data
let's say every for one minute we you
end up with very very tiny fence and
that leads to a huge blow up in the
query processing times because more
listing more fine listing etcetera it
just gets complicated so we need to
compact the small files as well but that
means and this along with that
reprocessing we need to do both of them
lead to these sort of complexities like
oh I want to replace this part a file
with that part a file and while in the
meantime the reporting job is actually
trying to read the Sparky files what you
ended up is getting a lot of file not
found exception z' because things are
moving around its inconsistent so you
need to schedule the reporting to not
run at the time where the compaction is
running and things got a little
complicated I see some of your smiling
yes a lot of our customers also had the
same problem which is what led us to the
drawing board that what is the right way
of doing this thing and that's where we
did Derek's Delta so dynamics Delta is a
storage solution that allows the scale
of data leaks it has a reliability in
performance of data warehouses and it
provides the low latency that streaming
pipelines require let me so what do I
mean by that and so the the greatness of
data warehouses is that you have data in
pristine quality in purely structured
form you get transaction reliability and
you obviously get fast queries because
it's super optimized databases are super
optimized to do that whereas there are
lakes you have massive scale on the
cloud storage you can just dump files
onto it usually people do it in really
open formats like Park and oak or C and
because of its drop in nature you can do
all sorts of complex analytics on top of
it machine learning streaming etcetera
now to combine the best of both of these
worlds we we could do these were like
for example data because Delta it's
naturally built on the spark and
decouple compute and storage
architecture so it can horizontally
scale out really well it provides the
reliability guarantees of data
warehouses because it natively supports
asset transactions when updating data
and data validation etcetera things that
you expect out of a data warehouse data
warehouse
you get the performance of data lakes of
data warehouses because it also supports
caching and indexing that things that
you find only in data warehouse is not
typically in data lakes that well the
output format is still open and so you
can do all other kind of stuff on it
so that the benefit of data lakes do you
get there and all of this can be done at
low latency so it integrates very well
at streaming so this is how our new
pipeline looks like and this is very
similar to the fortune 5 the 1,400
company that was talking about we have
data from Kafka structure streaming
writing into a single massive data X
Delta table which has all the data in it
so we don't have two different pipelines
there is there's only one pipeline so
and from that massive database table we
spawn out more structures having
pipelines to create more final summary
tables that are specifically designed
and optimized for the specific workloads
like streaming analytics our reporting
and with this biplane going back to the
challenges we faced we don't have the
lambda architecture anymore it's one
single single pipeline we don't we
really don't need to do evaluation even
if we do need to do valuation between
old and new data it's all in the same
location so it's much easier and all
sorts of reprocessing and compaction
related problems the file not for an
exception there's goes out of the
picture because all of this because data
break supports this provides transaction
guarantees when updating data therefore
you will not ever see file not found
exception and all the little nasty stuff
like that so you don't need to worry
about any of that you can feel free to
schedule your reporting whenever and
your compaction job whenever any ways to
summarize Delta X Delta is part of the
data breaks offering we have a unified
analytics platform to solve all your
data processing needs be it data
engineering stuff or data science is
stuff and and and and we really build
this platform because we wanted to build
the same kind of we wanted to help
others build the same kind of data
pipelines that we had to build ourselves
and
structure swimming is recently a fast
scalable falter and suppressing engine
with high-level user-friendly API is
whereas Delta is the other part of the
end-to-end pipeline solution where we
solve all your storage problems by
giving the reliability of data
warehouses and the scalability of data
lakes you can read more on our blogs the
semi programming guide on our data
breaks Delta website huh and if you want
to learn more the best place to learn
more about latest and greatest is the
spark some it spotless a I submit now
and it is in from June 4 to 6 there are
still tickets available I highly
encourage is to come at the spark summit
and talk to us thank you very much thank
you so I'm wondering whether data bricks
Delta is open source and if it's not
like what's the kind of architecture and
what does it look like internally is it
something a little bit like kudu or so
dinner breaks Delta is not open source
it's part of our Derek's runtime
offering which is Dericks runtime is the
more optic
a more highly optimized version of a
patches part that we offer and
internally it essentially looks like a
bunch of parka files similar to a parka
table except the the consistency
guarantees of what parka files are
present etc is managed by a log that is
updated transactionally so at a very
high level it looks pretty much like a
database there is a log which is updated
transactionally and there is a bunch of
files which in case of databases
it used to be super optimized and
coupled with the engine here we just use
open formats to save those files so if
anyone wants to access those files from
outside there it's they are not blocked
from doing that
you